I'll pull this story from the New York
Post
White House big Tech colluded to censor
misinformation lawsuit good yeah New
York Post you can just show the emails
that came out showing that they
literally did it this is this is crazy
who's filing the lawsuit uh a bunch of
people I think it's Gateway pundits
involved the state of Missouri is
involved I think that's the that's the
lawsuit that where this is coming from
this uh I just had uh Jen and Eunice on
my show and it hasn't even come out yet
but she I'm going to look up her her
Association because she is co-plaintiff
with two attorneys generals on this and
this discovery is more like we knew this
was happening because the White House
was actually saying it from the podium
and Biden was saying Facebook is
literally killing people so this is not
actually news except they now have
documentation that there was a ongoing
coordination process where the
government was dictating to tech
companies what they were allowed to say
and what they were a lot they were
demanded to take off and it's now time
to sue Facebook into Oblivion anyone so
you need to look at the emails and look
at the stories anytime Joe Biden has
referenced covid policies
I think anybody who tried sharing
anything related to that should should
join a class action lawsuit against
Facebook and the US government for
collusion violation of First Amendment
rights because the government was
actively suppressing that information
with the assistance of Facebook and you
are now you should now all have standing
large class action
that would be fantastic I'd be involved
in that I remember posting in 2020 about
some coveted stuff about some documents
and after that totally blackballed like
blacklisted yeah and they they're no no
notice that it happened I just started
getting three likes per per post after
that and now my I'm sure my page is in
some kind of I mean YouTube took down
like what half a million probably more
than that videos that had to do with
code stuff and then change their policy
and didn't put the videos back up like
there is an obvious censorship element
to this that they are not willing to
answer for okay so here's I just want to
fill in the blank there the Jen and
Eunice who's with the new civil civil
liberties Alliance
and they are representing uh Jay
bhattacharya the the one of the signers
of the Great Barrington declaration
Martin koldorf a couple other guys and
they have joined the Louisiana Missouri
Attorneys General on this and I I think
it goes to the Supreme Court Louisiana
yeah oh wow I thought it was Missouri is
it two Missouri and Louisiana wow yep
and uh this is going to be big I think
it's a big deal
um and and you know God help us we need
to save the first amendment I still
think that matters
I agree is that crazy am I I don't know
no we need to evolve the First Amendment
because we're creating a global
government right now and I think free
software code is the future Free Speech
if you can see what the code is doing
then that's like your sense of personal
freedom in the environment if you go to
the metaverse and you can't see what the
code is doing around you it could be
telling you lies and you wouldn't know
it well so could a human
it's okay for humans to lie but for a
software code for an environment to lie
to you I think is when it's gone too far
what does that mean like if there's
blatant lie propaganda like if there's
signs around you that are telling you
something happened when it didn't yeah
that's the metaverse I'm talking about
when you're in VR when you're in but
like this image posted by a person
what's the difference is I guess between
what and what I'd like an image posted
by a person and a person saying the
words if someone creates an environment
that they post false advertising or they
post you know false statement and
political ads it's created by a person
even if it is a sign that's physically
appearing yeah if I saw a sign that said
like turn right to the next Burger King
but to you the sign said turn left to
the next Burger King and but neither of
us know that we're getting fed different
information that's like a violation of
my first amendment that's a violation of
my of a human right in my opinion people
need to know if they're being led
towards yeah you said it's okay if
people well that means why like why
technically you could lie to me if you
have an algorithm that's decided you
should go to Wendy's and you should go
to Burger King and it's automatically
doing it yeah we should know that
machines are doing that to us when
people don't realize you know Facebook
experimented on people do you guys know
this
they they they made people depressed on
purpose to see what would happen that's
psychotic
we should have a we should have a right
guarantee that they can't do that there
should be I mean I think we should
abolish algorithmic feeds it should be
chronological and your followers so if
you follow something you get shown it it
shouldn't be like we've decided what's
right for you because Facebook actually
started showing people content that
would depress them to see if it would
work and it did they started then
producing depressing content it's creepy
stuff it's like 2014 I think they were
doing that what are they doing now
oh yeah exactly Mark Zuckerberg is a
he's a psycho he's I think he's in a big
time into psychology that's a big part
of what this is for him as a psychology
experiment I mean he said that pretty
openly that he loves experimenting in
the human psychology I don't want to put
words in your mouth Mark but you've
alluded to that fact I think he was in
college for psychology at the time that
he was building Facebook
um yeah I agree man I you know we gotta
it's a new world and we gotta take it by
the horns if we don't it's gonna Gore us
do you guys um think that technology
this kind of social media technology
that is doing all this stuff is this
generally been a good thing or is this
what's creating all of this chaos it's
the chaos it's neutral but people are
using it to create massive chaos under
the guise of American law like property
ipe law I can't just own a world you
know technology is neutral but it's
basically like
you know crystal meth if you if you just
start Mass producing it and giving it
out to people and it's like imagine if
companies came around came out they
started giving up free crystal meth to
everybody in order to have a job you had
to have it it's like you're going to
come and work but you're on meth right
and you know that would be insane we can
see the problem with that drug addiction
but what social media is is exactly that
so when you have a group of people that
don't really have the cognitive
faculties to lead and I'm not trying to
be disrespectful to everybody but some
people are really dumb and some people
you can be disrespectful too if they
know they're manipulating but you have
people who are just
blindly Marching In lockstep with with
this uh gutter garbage algorithmically
fed nonsense you have to have it
they're creating a world of chaos and
nonsense and that's what the modern left
is I don't view it as a political
movement sort of you know I've talked
about this it's a it's it's a chaotic
destructive force it's like a fire
that's all it is it's like fire you have
the left and the right the traditional
left and right in this country and
that's why as I mentioned the other day
if I sat down with Ben Shapiro we're
going to disagree on your traditional
left and right disagreements and then
we're going to shake hands and be like
ah America's great but then you have
this left this quote unquote left which
is just a fire that burns there's no
reasoning with it
you could go up to it and you can say
here's a video of Joe Biden admitting to
a quid pro quo and they'll smack it out
of your hand and be like fascist fascist
fascist and just aren't screaming
because it's fire there's no Rhyme or
Reason
a leaderless mob blindly Marching In
lockstep on social media and that's what
you end up with but this is nothing new
in the entirety of human history has uh
um crazy mobs doing the most inhumane
things mass murder stuff but it's but
it's Amplified it's and it's addictive
like we we've always had crazy people
but we haven't always had systems that
incentivize you to post inflammatory
things Instagram right young girls are
getting depressed because they're not
getting enough Instagram likes now
they're doing photoshops and filters on
their on their apps now women are
getting plastic surgery to look like the
filters like this is derangement there's
a family that's suing Instagram because
their daughter started using it uh at a
young age like 13 or something and
develop really serious anorexia and
anxiety and and they believe that it's
directly correlated to her addiction to
social media well these CEOs don't give
their kids phones everybody else does
and it's like the dude's selling the
drugs knows not to let their kids have
it but the families are told to do it's
the right thing yeah so addictive
printing press fire drug we can we can
go back to Web 2.0 get rid of all these
weird algorithmic manipulations just go
back to reverse chronological that'd be
fantastic if you follow them you follow
them otherwise the posts just come in
and reverse chronological order I hear
the web is headed towards 3.0 and it's
freaking out humanists well we're in 3.0
3.0 is like the Perma web where
everything is on our weave or some other
permanent state where it's always there
and that's where you're talking about
4.0 geez I don't even know what to call
this stuff web 1.0 was like CompuServe
and AOL chat rooms really basic stuff
garbage websites Web 2.0 was when we got
social media websites accounts we're
popping up eBay and things like that you
could then do transactions online
through websites and then web 3.0 was
the app Network now now you're online
through an app that you you can't
navigate away from except the app itself
and then the app can shut you off things
like that that's why they're going to
web3 so when it first started you had
crazy websites and IPS and you'd see
like you know a gif of Macho Man doing
the peanut butter jelly dance or
whatever at hamster dance and things
like that then we got Web 2.0 which was
like YouTube and Myspace but they're
still desktop websites now you have web
3.0 where you don't actually type in it
anymore you have just apps and you press
it and you're logged in automatically
and you interact with them and they're
heavily regulated the internet used to
be fun because the Wild West Web 3.0 is
awful it's it's robotic it's it's it's
mundane yeah and then web four point I
was I don't know what they're like
expecting that to be like I don't know
it's it's the matrix it's we're gonna go
straight yeah neural link
um okay what about what about blockchain
as the alternative to this and and
there's some experiments well what is
what does that mean it means that we
could go back to the fun internet and we
could go back to the unregulated can you
just make it yeah this is a just there's
no appetite for it people aren't doing
it nothing there's nothing stopping you
from making you know bringing back an
AOL server with messenger and chat rooms
people don't do it well if we look at
what the FBI has been doing there are
things that can try and stop that from
happening unfortunately like they
stopped Facebook from letting things
happen on their website so before there
wasn't a lot of government overreach
that we knew about in the late 90s 96 97
when people were typing on AOL chat
rooms logs weren't being strong I don't
know if they still have those AOL chat
logs from 30 20 years ago if they want
them but the the technocratic state's
been in high alert for the last 20 years
and really building up a way to spy you
know the prism Network where they're
allowed I think legally even now XP
score yeah it's not right we publish all
of our stuff on Odyssey
um in the anticipation of YouTube
finally deciding that that our stuff
isn't allowed anymore and we're not
we're not going to be first we're not
Alex Jones we we tell Beautiful Stories
and and I don't expect to be the first
to get banned from anything but what
they want to do is they want to turn the
internet back into TV
they want to yeah that's exactly what
they want to do what the the big Tech
Guys and the government have been trying
to do is
when there was web 1.0 subcultures
started flourishing with Web 2.0 they
started solidifying and building
economics around themselves then they
realized hey wait a minute these people
actually got Trump elected they were
memeing him into into Power by making
jokes and people were sharing them it
was me magic and they said we have to
stop that
so now the goal is
approved narratives only on all of these
big platforms and that's it they started
Banning conspiracies and all the fun
content man it was it was it was a good
day you know back in what like 2010. I'm
super excited when you could watch Flat
Earth videos and they'd be on the front
page of YouTube and you'd be like Ah
that's so dumb and silly and now it's
like you go to the front page and you
got Mr Beast and you got CNN
but this this is the whack-a-mole that
I'm talking about is like every time
people get new tools to be more
liberated and think for themselves they
come in with a new scheme more
aggressive more authoritarian every time
they do it to try to shut it down and
then something else emerges and I I
think that there is a technological
solution because
um I don't want to live in a matrix and
I don't think most people do what
concerns me about the whack-a-mole thing
because you're right when people are
whacked down they tend the Consciousness
will rise up somewhere else and it'll
keep happening and they keep trying to
stop it but if you don't know you're
being whacked if you think everything's
going out normal but it's being tweaked
somewhere between you and The Listener
because of Out secret algorithms then
there might not be an uprising because
you don't even know you're being
manipulated that's what I'm concerned
with and I want to avoid well you can
see trends like young people make fun of
people that are on Facebook now that's
what Grandpa does and they've migrated
and they're they're curating their own
content they're watching shows like this
they're they're binge watching things on
Netflix and and they're all on YouTube
none of these none of these platforms
are completely free but they're more
free than the sort of manipulation on
Facebook I remember when we started free
the people we thought that young people
had short attention spans but it turns
out that Facebook manipulates you into
not paying attention for very long so
what happened uh people that didn't like
that they migrated to YouTube and and
other places
um I think that I mean I I believe in
the wisdom of crowds I believe that
people figured this stuff out and I
think that the the revolution is going
to be those people choosing for
themselves
I think the strange thing about the
internet is that it was so disruptive
and by uh regulating the internet you
can really regulate basically every part
of human life I've never had a job that
didn't in some way involve the internet
which is sort of crazy there are
Generations that that was not true for
even people who worked in Congress who
wrote bills like they you know before
the rise of the internet there were
other ways of operating and now I can't
imagine life without it not just that I
mean even if you work at a fast food
restaurant these days you have apps to
order food so you're getting the
internet into schedule which if you're
working I mean like everything is done
through the internet so if you mean that
like if you have to comply by the
internet aka the government's rules then
every part of your life has to comply
yep so we had uh Robert Davion the other
night he was telling us a really
interesting story in the after show
about uh I think it tells in the main
show like maybe it was after show how he
got how we ended up getting into uh no I
think it was after show how he got into
acting and he said that you'd have to
call a number on a pay phone that would
have your messages stored for you so
it's like he wakes in the morning he
runs down to a pay phone he puts the
coins in and then he dials a number and
he's like he gives his information and
then it reads him his messages and he
finds out he gets he gets the part like
that's crazy days yeah I remember when I
was a kid you know I'm 36. you go to
your friend's house knock on the door
he's not here do you know where he went
I don't guess I'm not going to see him
today how was life man the internet
before internet banking I know you
remember do you guys did you ever have
them before debit cards yeah before
debit cards you had a check you'd go to
the to Drug Mart and you'd be like
here's a check for 17 it would take
three days to clear then you'd have to
go to the bank and you like talk to the
cashier checks write her a check and
then she would give you cash then
internet banking appeared and it's so
convenient I can send I can click a
couple buttons and you get the money
it's amazing how could I ever want to
turn back from that except that now they
have the power to click a button and
turn it all off yeah maybe they kind of
did before or say send money to certain
people or you can't use this service
because we don't believe in your
ideology have y'all watched Catch Me If
You Can yeah what was that what was that
guy's name the the con man
well no Leo's the actor but his
characters was named I'm sure people in
the chat will give us his name but you
look at how easy it was
to con people back then like he made
fake checks like it actually wasn't that
difficult for him to do yeah he just
lied and they would do it reminds me of
that movie with Ricky Gervais The
Invention of Lying you ever seen that
one yeah where he goes into the bank and
he's like he needs money and then also
like nobody can lie in this world and
also in his brain just snaps and he goes
I have 800 and she goes it doesn't say
that we must have made a mistake here
you go and then she gives him the money
that's what it felt like watching Catch
Me If You Can oh the character is Frank
Abagnale Jr Frank Abagnale Jr yeah and
he was like he took uh in the movie with
the show is probably apocryphal it's
probably a movie but he bought little
toys with the Pan Am logo and then he
like soaked them and then peel the
sticker off and put it on the check to
make it look official man these days
everything's you know so much more
secure but but I will say I think it's
funny that we're all old people talking
about yo when I was a kid we had phones
on the wall and uh but the reality is
the real purpose of this is in in in
walking away from land lines in the more
we move into this digital space the less
control we have to the point where this
is the craziest thing
you don't even own your shows anymore
you don't own it's it's like you will
owe nothing and you will be happy I hope
everybody listening realizes that the
the the agenda of the world economic
Forum has been underway for a very very
long time
you own you don't you don't even own
your phone
the software on it is licensed to you
and at any moment apple or ant or Google
can brick your phone they can shut it
off like that if they want to
I remember 10 years ago Apple filed the
patent to create geo-fencing that if
your phone went into a certain area that
they deemed to be fenced off your camera
would not turn on
that's the world or you can buy a camera
and walk around with it they can't
control it a Polaroid or something like
that
I saw a funny tweet where some guy said
you know the future is inconvenient I
was flying on a plane flying on a plane
and my book ran out of batteries it's
like yeah that's that's the future you
know for convenience and you end up
losing control one of the most jarring
things is when I used to have all these
CDs I have like 500 400 CDs or something
I'd move around from place to place
every year and carry this big giant
Tupperware tub of CDs and then all of a
sudden it was digitized and people
didn't own their music anymore and I'm
like I I still haven't done it I won't
do it I still have my CDs they're my
parents house right now
um I have them all backed up on multiple
hard drives because that's music I
bought music I own as far as I'm
concerned I was never told that I didn't
own the CD and everything on it when I
bought it so I own that here's the best
part there's a this happened to a lot of
people they got banned from Facebook oh
so what people get banned from Facebook
right the only problem is they were
using Facebook login now all of a sudden
they can't log into any of the other
apps they had synced with and some of
them are Financial now that's crazy well
I've known people who you know use
Facebook personally and upload pictures
of you know whatever their kids their
life's going on and when Facebook blocks
them and deletes their account they lose
all of that so people I've known people
to lose videos of like their kids first
step because they put it on Facebook so
Grandma in a different state could see
it and it's gone and Facebook won't give
it to you uh well my pop culture crisis
we talk about how important it is to go
to flea markets and tag sales and
collect vhs's because you won't be able
to edit out the content and then you'll
always have it unfortunately VHS are not
like super stable I think CDs probably
hold up against weather and heat and
stuff like that a little bit better but
there is I think uh an interesting
Crossroads where people are going to
have to say like if it's really
important to me I should actually get a
physical copy that cannot be virtually
deleted Trump should have banned tick
tock
should have absolutely banned how I
agree kind of agree with you I don't
know if banning is the way yeah how
would that have worked out if he had
that I think he it was temporarily like
restricted wasn't it it was I think
under some conditions I mean there are a
lot of reports coming out right now and
I don't want to be too alarmist about it
but of in different states they're
getting back their uh like learning
standards from last year they evaluated
kids and so many kids are behind yeah
and I think a lot of that is because
lockdowns were bad but also we didn't
intervene on the parts of the internet
that we should have and I don't actually
like intervention so it's hard for me to
say that but the tick tock thing is that
China is controlling what our kids are
seeing and they're banning shows like us
we got banned for no reason they just
nuked us off the platform and it's
obvious they want kids to see
their moral ideology so they'll grow up
and they'll not agree with this that's
their plan they want your kids so
conservatives have to win on the
education front and on that front and uh
Trump Banning it would have been a
seriously bad day for the welcome
cultists and from what I've understood
and read about the algorithm for tick
tock they actually
changed the algorithm based on what what
country they're in so kids in China are
not served the same content that Tick
Tock users who are under the age of teen
in America are you know you might get
more engineering content served to you
if you're a teenager in China than you
would in America right that is in
America it's well garbage in China they
don't allow it so so you know someone
chatted that kids aren't watching uh
YouTube they're watching Tick Tock
actually there were several studies and
some polls done and found that YouTube
is the most popular video platform for
for all ages but Tick Tock is very very
prominent among kid so if they're at
school they're probably on you know and
there's an ecosystem right so if you
have a Creator who's popular on Tick
Tock they probably also have a YouTube
channel and an Instagram and you're
floating between sort of but they're not
going on YouTube until they get home
they're on Tick Tock when they're on
their phone but Tick Tock is
creepy
Chinese controlled data being sent to
them there's a new style of
entertainment on Tick Tock where it's
like they'll say a thing and then
there's a cut and then they'll say
another thing and then there's a cut and
then they'll say a third thing and then
there's a cut and it's like those
disjointed three second statements edit
it all together as if it's to be one
sentence as opposed to like just a 10 or
30 second Converse statement oh bro
here's the here's the best thing so uh
some YouTubers figured out that typos
result in higher engagement because when
you have a typo in your title people
click it and then correct you so they
started intentionally putting typos in
the headlines children then started
spelling the words wrong because on
YouTube they were spelled wrong and
that's what they were exposed to
in that in that crazy
anything to drive viewers and to keep
them there right like that's why tick
tocks uh like shows your video and you
immediately scroll in some ways that's
why YouTube adopted shorts I think
because they want you to be able to move
quickly through a lot of content thanks
for checking out this segment from the
timcast IRL podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
Monday through Friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the timcast IRL podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there